Adam andeve.com is the place to go to
bring more pleasure and satisfaction
into your bedroom and they're offering
50% off just about any item plus free
shipping which includes Rush processing
just enter code Lifeline at checkout
we'll talk about this more later on in
the show anyway I kept going dude six
six six the devil the devil you knew I
was going to say that
dude I knew you're going to say that
to did you know I knew you going to say
that knew that's awesome I knew knew I
knew you were going to say that Tony
Robins Tony I knew it gun
dude
Runk hello
hello
hello hello will
helloo 50% is a lot baby baby good for
Christmas what's up episode 88 uh it's
cool to say 88 like this
888888888 no no it's very cool it's
episode 808 888888 that's not cool it's
Sunday December 17th W about that not
interesting crazy it actually is weird
that it's so close to Christmas and it's
coming up here um patreon.com Lifeline
luxury go on over to Lifeline luxury
dude let me tell you
something/ Lifeline luxury what I say
just left out the slash slash is
essential otherwise you won't go to the
site all right but I'm I I'm saying a
horror movie director slash is essential
but dude I what I'm saying is uh it'll
be a great thing to get for Christmas
for somebody be amazing it would also be
a great because you can get it for a
year for somebody oh yeah but also what
you can do is watch it over the holidays
oh yeah you know what I'm saying just
have the family gather around you know
what else you can do we're family your
family it's like one big family is get
my special christ.com watch it this
holiday season instead of hanging out
with your family watch it with your
family so you don't have to talk to them
right or you can get them tickets to
come see me in Sacramento you can come
see get tickets to see me in Brea and
Phoenix and El Paso and also Albuquerque
and that's that and that's that you do
your part I'm going to go to get a water
all right man I'm going to do this all
on my own which is interesting because I
got the podcast that is all on my own
coming up soon it's called the private
go submit yourself as a potential guest
on this tell me a an amazing story uh
and share it with the world on the
private record go to the private
record.com follow us on Instagram and
Tik Tok obviously subscribe on YouTube
we're coming out real soon back and I'm
excited uh what else what else what else
you want to be on this show click the
link in the description below or just go
to watch lifeline.com appreciate you and
look thank you for listening to this
podcast thank you for being a part of
this podcast and thank you if you
subscribe to the patreon uh you keep the
show going we appreciate you and really
it's really fun to do this podcast I
like doing it and I don't want to stop
so let's keep going also you want some
last minute gift ideas o no no no no no
no no no we're not doing that touching
we're not touching that I'm going to
talk about it in a minute so just hold
your horses on that last minute gifts
Lifeline merch.com you said that didn't
you no I didn't no I no I effing didn't
what I want to know is you like the
Tangerine L I decided and I don't know
how I feel about this I'll let you you
know when we're halfway through the show
to not bring a perer on air this episode
and bring a lroy this is a tangerine
lroy I prefer orange lroy but this will
have to do dude
QVC we've got a beautiful
lroy tangerine
lroy and you know it's absolutely
unbelievable look at this
beautiful color yellow
orange says right there
Tangerine naturally
essenced what does that even mean you
know that's nothing it basically means
it tastes
like maybe you thought about
Tangerine zero calor if you're talking
about calories there's zero if you're
talking about total fat there's Z zero
if you're talking about total
sodium zero why you do it so loud if
you're talking about
carbohydrates zero if you're talking
about
protein
zero ingredients are carbonated water
and it is naturally Essence now what
does it mean there H here's the thing
about now here's the thing about lroy
there cannot be something that tastes
like something if it's not in there so
it is absolutely cancer
causing there cannot be something in
here that tastes like
Tangerine that they are saying it is not
in here it can't be okay it is something
in here but they are saying it's nothing
it's cancer they're
saying
the only thing in
here is
water legitimately that's the only thing
that they are saying that's in here and
it tastes like
Tangerine this is why is nobody talking
about how impossible this
is made every single person who was
watching turn it off already it
simply can't happen okay right yeah we
can all agree yeah we selling it for
this this time only it's okay you just
drank cancer it's okay dude why do they
do that do what there's something in
there no one does what you did there's
something in there and they're saying
there's nothing in there it tastes like
something so there's something in there
so what is it ingredients carbonated
water that's all it says carbon in water
comma naturally
essenced what is that we don't know but
obviously they're getting away with it
by just like there's there's an aster
asterisk next to Essence and it all it
is the asterisk all it means is non GMO
so Essence all it means according to
this can is that it's non gml but what
is it if it that's what I'm the
definition of a thing the definition of
a thing can't be non that's exactly what
I'm saying they're saying it's not in
there but it's in there no is they're
not saying it's not in there they're
saying for only $2 this naturally
essenced whatever is non GMO but what is
naturally essenced exactly it's not in
there but it's in there $2 wow what the
what is it is cancer it will kill you
this beautiful
lroy sparkling water and there's too
many words on the front here too so
that's great actually think the tastes
better than Perry is out of control and
here's what I can't believe okay there
was one literally before we started this
there was one perer left in the
refrigerator and like dozens of lroy you
and I have had this discussion many
times you always say lroy is better you
chose knowing I exist to have the very
last perier in the refrigerator now
why'd you do that to gift you the
absolute beauty of Tanger now there's
too many letters words on here sparkling
water Tangerine naturally Essence lacroy
that's too many we can all agree on that
you didn't answer my question I I I I
don't like that trash [__] what is that
what what Tangerine lroy there's lime
there's PL there lime in there yeah you
still chose to can take the very last
Perry knowing that I thrive and survive
on Perry I like Perry better now you do
okay well now at least that's a good
reason Chang I like better now good it's
better sorry stick you with the
Tangerine here's the thing though no I
like it's fine okay obviously I like
that better but okay I'm going rub it in
perier is twice as expensive as the Croy
right I I rarely am like something's
better just cuz it's expensive but when
something's $5 or $10 the chances of the
thing that's $10 being better are
exponentially high and yet there are
people in this world who actually say to
my face straight to it lroy tastes
better than perryer you're crazy you're
absolutely
crazy if you want your water to taste
like really shitty water down candy here
I go here you go I got the thing that's
right for you if you want your water to
taste like water there you go it's over
there my brother took the last one
didn't let me have it you're doing a a
QVC for per then yeah but I'm doing it
from the heart I know okay I want to be
a QVC guy dude rate my rate my
hair did you just recently touch it
maybe cuz it was going around like nine
zone now it's down to like seven and
half eight oh come on dude you touched
it you was in the nine Zone it was like
going crazy over there it looked cool
you think it was in the nine Zone yeah a
Matt Damon movie The Nine
Zone rate my hair Matt Dam I'm saying
Matt Matt Damon in the in the trailer oh
oh it needs to be higher the worst movie
ever the nine Zone the [__] worst
movie of all time Brian Cox is like
we're out of four right now it needs to
be higher the nine Zone you know
introducing a Latino
male God lat uh Latino I was going to
say Latino mes instead of uh Matt Damon
movies wow that's so stupid Matt Damon
movies three out of four of them are the
shittiest looking things in the world
okay well we don't
downsizing nothing ever looked stupider
than that we bought a zoo nothing ever
looked stupider than that uh the The
Adjustment Bureau with the [__] that
I saw nothing ever looked dumber with
the hats and then every once in a while
he'll do a movie
where I look I haven't seen this movie
but I still know I say this all the time
uhhuh Matt Damon gives the best
performance of all time in the movie
Still Water I haven't seen it but we all
know that he does right cuz he's got
like the hat on and he's like I'm from
Oklahoma you know what I mean right and
he's they made that movie I want my
daughter they make that movie every year
though yeah but he's so good in that
movie even though I didn't see it you
know he's so good in that movie dude you
think yeah dude all right you think that
he won the Oscar he not nominated what
year was it that's the Sham I haven't
seen it but I know they don't give the
Oscars for the best stuff I mean
sometimes they do but yeah they don't
nominate all the best stuff they it's a
popularity contest and that's what sucks
yeah or they also it is usually or very
often that but they also have the worst
taste the academy has AB [__] taste yeah
yeah dude greenbook won an Oscar Avatar
won best cinematography like what crash
one best picture crash yeah dude what
Slum Dog Millionaire one
Slum Dog Chamillionaire one [__] best
picture dude
unbelievable what is that Matt Damon
movie where he's like talking to himself
the whole time it's really funny oh the
the informant yes that's one of the four
out of one of the one out of the four
that is great but three out of four look
like the innards of an [__] they see
me they see me
ring aren they on a boat sometimes in
that I mean maybe they see me rowing
we're
Brown wow Worst lyrics
dirty so bad we're [__]
Hindi okay red
dots we're dirty we're going to stop it
now and we're let me get some curry
curry Anthony love that
dude uh Slum Dog Chamillionaire baby I
want some non
bread
dude there's a old decrepit dying dog in
here that is asleep and with that laugh
you just woke his ass up scared the
[__] you almost killed him give me some
cumin some non
bread and some Curry got to get some
indigestion R and dirty
SL
Chamillionaire oh [__]
dude [__] man a stupid
s oh [__] dude wow you and Anthony huh
oh
[__] I love stupid [__] dude I hate you
know I hate [__] jokes dude I just
like you just made a [__] joke that
lasted four minutes it's dumb it's dumb
dude I yeah I agree [__] I agree dude
non
bread I don't even know if that's Indian
non bread is Indian you mean you don't
know if the movies is IND no no no no no
I have no idea about anything I just
said honestly you don't have an idea
about anything
period just in general it's what makes
it better dude oh [__] man oh man my
face hurts I was laughing so hard the
give a BJ what are you doing I'm about
to give a BJ dude chill out all right
you want to get get into it or what the
[__] man you know it's like Jesus Christ
El start man you done
yeah hey Matt and Chris this is lety I
love you guys I've seen Chris l a few
times and I can't wait for the next
one so we the S is yeah yeah now you got
to start over I know I'm sorry I thought
you said hey guys this is
[__] hey guys this is
hob all right let's do
it hey Matt and Chris this is lety I
love you guys I've seen Chris Love a few
times and I can't wait for the next
one I need advice as with something so
we live on a busy street and um when
turning right um it's kind of like a
tight turn because of the heavy traffic
and usually because people park right on
top of the little entrance and the curb
has a little area painted red and people
still Park like way past it even like
not even respecting it like past it all
already so
mad so um it makes it kind of unsafe
turning into our home when there's
traffic and everything um so we ended up
getting a cone and we put it right there
where the painted area is and people are
moving the cone like
oh is it just me I would never move the
cone TI one time I found the cone by a
tree like super far away so people are
moving the cone and still parking in the
way we get what should I do pop advice
is appreciated if you see well leave a
note if if it's a that sucks though you
know how many different people probably
park there all the time like yeah if if
if you notice one in particular leave no
always leave a note have a a printed
note like zero zero copy make a 100
copies of your note yeah um and if you
see someone keep doing it pop their
tires like you see a repeat offender
yeah that's so [__] up to pop their
tires I wouldn't pop their tires but oh
then why are you because if I I did it a
few times and someone po my tire after
they give me a note I would be like I
kind of deserve it I would genuinely
think
that yeah wouldn't you no because my
tire would be popped and I'd be too mad
to be able to see reason maybe like the
next day I would be able to but in that
moment I'd be like somebody just popped
my [__] tires at that point honestly
I would thank the game dude that's the
game and I would be like you know what
the game got me today thank you game
thank you game live by the game die by
the game okay but I'm serious I
understand but do you believe me chill
out dude yes
believe me okay uh I agree it sucks when
people don't believe you dude when you
when you mean when you mean business I
mean bus people are like uh-huh you know
what I mean yeah and I I mean absolutely
business I don't like that I mean
absolutely business you uh damn
it a pirate a pirate forign Lo the plank
made absolute
business the [__] was I going to say
it's all good God NAB it it's okay you
were talking about the the the popping
at tires and the reason you don't see
reason and
uh yeah that that is I feel for you that
is a shitty situation dude but uh the
cone was a good idea the problem with
the cone idea was that it was a good
idea like I said but it would it was so
obviously not going to work yeah I agree
you know what I mean yeah it was just so
obviously not going to work that it was
a bad idea uh good thought bad execution
it was obviously not going to work um I
have so many cones but uh what I have so
many cones traffic cones in your
possession do I have them in my garage
why for things like that oh do they work
no never and I and I do it all the time
and it never works and you know what I I
just thought about though put why I have
so many I want get more put six out
there exactly that just thought that
putting one is just a an atrocious idea
line them and create like a rectangle of
them like don't even like have an empty
middle of them like so it really seems
like or dude you mean absolute business
just put a bunch of nails
down
but that's so antagonistic like it's
it's you don't want to get into that
kind of thing especially because you
live there if you worked there maybe but
you you don't want to do that kind of
thing around the place you live you
start a war people are going to be like
War doing [__] up [__] you know yeah
um I don't know what you can do though
honestly when they're I mean maybe when
they're in the Red Zone call like the
Red Zone The Red Zone with Matt Damon
yeah he actually literally was in a
movie called the green zone yeah which
is amazing um it needs to be read the
Red Zone the most on theose dialogue
it's not red yet dude can you the zone
is only green can I be quiet can you I
mean no I know the answer to that I
would never ask that it's more funny to
be loud yeah well it's funnier to be
loud but and then sometimes it's funny
to be quiet is there anyone to call like
if someone parks in a z Ghostbusters man
what can you call like some kind of
[__] Authority if someone's parked
it's a ghost that parked you can call
Ghostbusters but besides that
and pissed dude I mean yeah you can call
somebody for parking enforcement of
course you can I didn't know that and
tow the car tow the car if you park in a
Red Zone starting Mt Damon you get you
get pulled who do you call though Matt
Damon no who do you call for realon who
do you call that's what the movie's
about Matt Damon he's a parking
enforcement you call the [__] uh uh
um
city oh 1800
City
what does that even
mean need more numbers you
know I I I think you call parking
enforcement you just you can just call
great idea how do I report legal parking
oh yeah you can yeah you're right I you
didn't know this dude 24-hour oh that's
amazing well people come Park 24 hours
what do you mean of course you I didn't
realize actually didn't know this I
didn't know this I mean I if I thought
it if I ever thought it through I
probably would have been like there must
be but I never have thought to do
it that's the problem you didn't think
it through yeah well relax it's not the
problem no but it is the problem because
now we have Google we just rely on it
right yeah we just relied on it now saw
find the information I saw a meme the
other day and this was so this was so
interesting okay you know the Leonardo
Caprio where he's uh in Django and he's
the meme where he's drinking the thing
and he's like this yeah yeah yeah all
right so it said uh teacher to me when I
was in fifth grade or whatever uh well
you won't be able to carry you you won't
be able to um carry a calculator around
in your pocket all the time you know you
how teachers used to say that oh right
yeah and then it said me and like this
like cuz we do we have in our pocket all
the time you just explained a meme
though that is the most thing you cannot
do ever in the history of the world did
you know that I don't think I knew that
no did you think about it now though
what do you think about it now that you
think about it explaining a meme yeah
like that isn't in front of someone
trying to explain I mean he not I think
there's worse things I think there more
boring things M like murder more boring
things no more boring things are more
boring things H yeah like what I have a
friend listening to him talk is way
boring more boring than that but but on
in your defense it's interesting because
wow how is he being so boring so in a
way I'm kind of like it's interesting
yeah yeah so you might be right about
that up I'll say it's up there but it's
okay it's okay that I did that
that's how you started saying that I
sneaking out snu
out came out of the bathroom and snuck
out so hard he walked out of the
bathroom and looked around like he was
in a car at an intersection like dude
did the shadiest [__] in the world in
there injected
PCP all right let's do another one
injected PCP who wants better sex and
who wants to start having better sex
immediately I think I probably I think
everyone does and the best way to get
started is to go to Adam andeve.com
right now ad offering 50% off just about
any item and free shipping which
includes Rush processing what that's
right and more than that Adam and Eve
wants to make your life easy they offer
discreete shipping as your privacy is a
priority plus plus 100% free shipping
with Rush processing on your entire
order so bring more pleasure and
satisfaction to your bedroom it's 50%
off one uh item free shipping with free
rush rush saying go to Adam andeve.com
and select any one item it could be an
adventurous new toy or anything you
desire just enter offer code Lifeline at
checkout that's Lifeline l i f l i n
Adam an.com this is an exclusive offer
specific to this podcast okay so be sure
to use this code Lifeline to get your
discount 100% free shipping and get it
fast with Rush processing code
Lifeline good day fellas sty and
basically my question is from Ireland on
the Northern Hemisphere currently in New
Zealand on the Southern Hemisphere
and I'm wondering what your thoughts are
on spending six months of the year uh on
the Northern Hemisphere getting
summertime and then coming to the
southern hemisphere getting the
summertime here for do or six months
that year that's all
your that's it well Matt what are your
thoughts well my thoughts
are wow you
said different places geographical
places 85% of the words in that
submission were geographical I'm from
Ireland I'm in New Zealand and sometimes
I go to Australia what are your
thoughts no what he's saying is what are
your thoughts on living half the year
one place and half the year another
place I think that's not great because
you're just if you're just experiencing
summer
everywhere summer everywhere starring
Matt D damn it it's winter what the [__]
[__] can't
Beth it's not good I feel like that's
probably not good for your body or brain
to have it always be summer like it's
the same as like people where it's
daylight for a whole season it's like
that's [__] with your brain so drunk
[__] with your brain that's so good
dude I want that what I like that snow
bunnies snowbirds what do they call them
snowbirds mhm yeah snowbirds they go so
like my uh my mother-in-law she lives in
uh North Carolina but then when it's
freezing she goes to
Arizona like right okay yes but it's not
that's not what he's saying he's
literally shifting hemispheres which
means it's actually summer in the in the
place that he goes he's never not
experiencing summer sure okay in Arizona
it's still winter when she leaves yeah I
I know what you're saying it's just
warmer you're acting like warmer winter
I'm like warmer winter starring Matt
Damon what the [__] dude how about the
actual fracking movie Matt Damon was in
like that's such a piece of sh [__]
stinky [__] dude what is it who is it
what's it called him and John krinski
and it's like he's just like in a town
somewhere and is it called what the
Frack yeah yeah and like it's it's
fracket Frack don't talk back you know
what I would you know what I've never
known and I won't know what fracking is
and I will die not knowing what fracking
is you know what's really true though as
well people who right Anthony yes the
[__] is fracking people who so many
people explain are hardcore anti
fracking also don't know what fracking
is and that's annoying
I will never dude I will never dude it's
like a really unsafe bad for the
environment way of extracting oil and it
or natural gas and and and what you just
said is the most boring thing to listen
to and they made a movie about it that's
the thing I mean look talking about it
getting your pennies into joint about it
I get it cuz environmentalism and all
that [__] I'm not like that but I get it
I get how one could be for sure but
making a movie about it dude also Gus
Van s directed that come on he's great
but he does some boring [__] clearly but
but no but no what I'm saying is he
makes a point sometimes to make his
movies boring which I love Gus vanand
but that on a gus vanand level holy
[__] [__] like if Peter Berg did it'
be like it might be [__] fresh right
but that's different that's a different
kind of boring than you're right
tracking is absolutely so that's like a
movie [__] Matt Damon and sing just
[__] yeah yeah well that would be
better summer fall sleep all over again
that would be better because you'd be
like holy [__] they made a movie about
it Matt Damon sleeping that what the
nari
Nar this summer Matt Damon in
breathing that's in the
trailer I like I think the most boring
name title for a movie could and I think
this might actually be a movie waiting
yeah it is a movie waiting dude isn't
that a movie with uh is that Ryan
Rand Dane Cooks in it right waiting
right well they did they did
it but that it's a comedy though right
it's about like restaurant so like being
a waiter so it's it's even worse than it
has the ellipses afterwards you did it
even worse than I could have possibly
imagined myself what do you mean there's
an ellipses at the end of the title what
do you mean wow that is worse waiting
dot dot dot I thought ellipses was this
by mistake I I [__] it up par waiting
and then there's a movie called still
waiting Skyler Stone's in one of them I
think that do that doesn't matter oh no
he's great oh yes Skyler okay
yeah um wow I mean waiting I guess it
was a hit huh no I sequel they did yeah
it's still waiting I think it's a cult
classic it is it is it is but that's the
movie a [__] no I remember that's the
movie slick [__] silver shaft that's
that was the movie that uh Ryan Reynolds
was like okay he's in in going to be in
movies now I remember cuz remember he
was the guy in the pizza three guys
girls at pizza place show wasn't he in
that I think he was in that sitcom whoa
I don't know Ryan Reynolds history like
this I do even Ryan reynolds's name
slips through my brain like how could
you have that name dude you know who's
like that for me up until really
recently is uh Ryan Gosling dude I can
never remember that guy's last name but
he's interesting in yeah yeah no he's
very interesting well I think Ryan
Reynolds is cool as [__] is he yeah I
just don't I don't even know he his [__]
is just in my brain and then right back
out Ryan Reynolds has gone here's the
deal like Ryan Reynolds or not he's
gotten to the point where he's been
around so long that you kind of got to
be like okay I I think I like him
because he he doesn't he's not like the
rock where he's just always doing
something and it's annoying as [__] he's
riding around like I'm going to do
Deadpool and kind of that that's it and
also I'll be in another movie maybe and
then I have a company that I'm going to
sell for $900 trillion so what's the
differ that is what the Rock does
literally quiet about it though what do
what do you mean he's everywhere dude
he's like air you can't turn around and
not see Ryan Reynolds in some ad for
some company I've never [__] heard of
um yeah I guess I don't know I'm not
even anti- ran reyolds
guys at that level they're not even
actors anymore they're just entities I
tell you what I was 100% commitment
committed I was 100% committed saying
what I was saying and I don't even
believe it right and I don't care enough
but it goes to show that's how people
are when they get behind something it's
like you don't actually but but but but
but I'm different because what I did is
I'm saying right afterwards I get it and
I admit it yeah yeah that makes you
different you're right yeah I don't you
know like if I believed in qanon and
then it all fell I'd be like okay qon
isn't real I wouldn't still believe in
qon but a lot of people still believe in
qon because they've been believing in Q
and not yeah hold on they hold on it's
called it's called holding on that's not
a another terrible title for a movie but
that's not what it's called that's just
no it's it's called holding on no
holding on is just something you can say
about something but it's not called and
I say it about that so it's called that
all right well let's do another
submission okay
okay y what's up Matt what's up Chris my
second time on the show nice first time
I was on I asked a question about um
what what to do if your best friend
likes a girl but the girl likes
you I uh appreciate the responses on
that I wasn't really actually going
through that situation at the moment I
uh I was just thinking about it I was
like damn that's kind of a good question
to ask like you
scario anyways I have another question I
want to ask you guys so honest
opinion is it uh is it as creepy
oh as it is to me to you guys if one of
your friends or just some male friend
constantly calls their dad daddy oh
that's cuz I got to be honest with you I
don't like it and it's and it's never
just like a normal daddy like we
literally have a friend and he says it
in the most creepy [__] way he's like
I love you Daddy whoa okay Daddy oh yeah
I mean I'm not picking on anybody that
calls their dad daddy it is what it is I
just wanted to know what your guys'
opinion was on that that's [__] weird
by the way the nose ring doesn't look
too weird with the tatto tattoos right
no it's good let me know what you guys
think wow just should have only wanted
to know about the nose ringing of the
tattoos you know just literally admitted
he made up a whole thing yeah twice
right good point and then at the very
end snuck in the thing he actually cares
about good point yeah the nose ring in
the tattoos [__] what like you
actually think someone walks by you dude
and is like what the [__] with that
guy's nose ring I mean I don't know I
might no that no one does that yeah they
go they flow with the [__] rest of
his whole vibe yeah I get it I so like
he saying he's asking saying not so bad
with the tattoos right you get it I
think right means but but I think what I
think what he's saying is I think what
he's alluding to is we probably talked
about a nose ring before on the show and
said it was silly is that even with him
might have I don't know that's what I'm
getting but who knows what the Frack but
like uh what was the question again Dad
guys who call dad's dad dude
that's that
I don't does anyone do that that's so
extremely
weird but also it could just be normal
for their family but it's still very it
doesn't necessarily mean anything but
it's but it's very weird it's like if
you're going to call if you're a grown
man and you want to call your father
your dad daddy you got to be like funny
about it or something it's odd yeah
that's that's it's odd you can't be like
here's the Daddy I love you Daddy here
there's so many there's too many
connotations with Daddy now here's what
it is it you have to understand that if
you do that people are going to think
it's weird that's the thing exactly
number and you still do it whatever if
you call your dad daddy and you're a
grown man you also have to be worth a
billion dollars cuz that's something
that if you're you're you're an oil
family yeah I mean if you're poor and
you're just like coming home to a
one-bedroom apartment just like hey
Daddy yeah the Vander buils do that the
DuPont do that the bushes but you got to
wear an way the bushes don't do that you
have to wear yeah 100% an ascot by the
way it's even weird to call your mom
mommy if you're a grown man
okay it's [__] weird I do that
specifically as a joke a joke yeah right
which is to imply which is another way
to say that's really weird right I do
that specifically as a joke swear to God
[Laughter]
um but yeah and by the way daddy is so
weird you don't even do that as a joke
no you don't even make that joke you
don't even make that joke no hey Daddy
oh that's [__] weird that feel very
do that imagine calling dad daddy do it
say hey Daddy hey Daddy do that feel
weird hey Daddy do that feel weird yeah
not that weird though no I'm thinking
about other stuff like Hey Dad da that
would be like funnier d da dad da yeah
but that's just funny I know cuz I'm
just thinking it through though you know
what I mean like Daddy yeah no it's not
good Dad mobile let's take the Dad
mobile like he's in the other room
daddy no
n that's weird yeah you know
what has nobody ever told that dude that
no one's done that he made that up he
made that up somebody does it he
admitted he made it up like about I
understand his track record is not good
but my son Calvin sometimes calls me
Daddy and it is [__] I I know it's
the cutest thing in the [__] world
yeah I love that he calls me Dad Dad D I
love that he calls me dad daddy anything
you are his d i that's I'm saying I
that's what I love I love when he calls
me Dad and I think I'm that boy's dad
like I I I I love that I love that and I
tell him I love being his dad all the
time it's so awesome and I can't wait to
tell tell that to Billy and have him
have the wherewithal to be like oh or
okay Dad and have him call me dad to
have two [__] sons call me dad is
going to be so
awesome worst monologue where monolog in
to play the best one and it starts out
with that that's the beginning of the
play yeah be yeah yeah all right you you
want to keep going or you after the guy
after the guy from the side stage that's
been sitting there the whole time while
the audience trickled in says there was
a story once about you know what I mean
like I hate plays that start with the
actor already out there when the people
are trickling in oh yeah you know what
I'm saying I do and and everyone CU
everyone's sitting down they're like oh
you see we can see you see him
yeah nah dude start the play when
everyone's settled and then start to
play yeah have the guy come out then
with the banjo all right
next what's up Chris what's up
Matt guys I sent in a video a couple
weeks ago about you know selling my hair
for
$125,000 to Chris and look you guys I
think we all know I was joking around
well yeah man um you know Matt
especially you cuz he was like that
seems like a bad deal you know which of
course it is that would be practically
giving away so oh wow so you know
clearly I was joking around I know I
can't sell you my hair you know what I'm
saying and here's what I want to say
this is probably most important is [__]
you you know if I could Chris I wouldn't
make you buy my hair I would I would
give it to you as a charity um it
wouldn't even be about like a tax write
off thing either it would be a complete
charity um so you know now you know here
here's the thing I don't put the videos
up on there so it's like you know
someone put that video up thinking that
it might be something for you to take
into consideration that's all I'm saying
but anyways I do have an advice question
today um wow listen guys I'm not good at
saving
money how do I become rich and famous so
I don't have to worry about saving money
that's a good question dude that that is
such a good question how do I get rich
and the famous part doesn't matter but
how do I get rich so that I don't have
to worry about money that is such a good
question yeah but it's so
relatable you know think about it it's a
relable it's a really good everyone
wants to know the answer to that
question don't they yeah I think so if
how how do I get rich yeah yeah I mean
well you know it how do I get rich yeah
well the reason it's such a good
question is because there's very
obviously no answer cuz if there was an
answer every single person would do it
there would be nobody poor which means
there wouldn't even be anybody rich
either we be live in a communist society
and no one wants that but also there's
there there's so many uh there's so many
answers to that yeah you can develop a
skill and grind for years you can invest
in business but there's no Surefire ways
is what it is yeah yeah of course not
you could be IM immensely talented at
something and then you'd have like a
better chance than someone else who
isn't immensely talented at that thing
to get rich but even
then you know it's not likely nobody's
almost nobody's Rich the other thing is
he said how do I get rich so I because
he doesn't know how to save dude you got
to save to get rich well that is that is
there in lies your issue is that yeah
you got to figure out a way to save
money even if you're you have a low
paying job job like mhm saving
is so important I'm also terrible at it
but I absolutely recognize the
importance of it put a little bit of the
money away every time you make some put
it
in well what saving money I think so
well yeah I mean probably well you're
definitely better than me yeah I mean I
just like yeah dude really there's a
[__] hole in my pocket yeah do you
think that uh what do you think that is
a in therapy I mean do I think that is
for one I make way less money than you
no no no no I know but but but but if
you're making a money and then you still
want to spend the money what do you
think it is I mean it doesn't matter how
much money you have want more of the
money spend more of it and that's and
then I do that I understand but and then
I have less but all I'm saying is it has
nothing to do with the amount of money
you have if you are a person that likes
to spend money you just you you're that
kind of person so what is it about get
getting the money and wanting to get rid
of it to get stuff for it I don't want
to get rid of it I want to keep it but I
don't have enough of it to to live the
way I want to live the way I want right
and also save is difficult with the
amount of money I make I understand that
but if you were to make $30 million a
year which is a little bit more than I
do yeah would you think that you'd still
have that problem no right so then
you're not really a person like that
yeah but that's true of almost everyone
I don't know no well yeah okay I guess
so St like MC Hammer you know MC Hammer
is the one guy who you you could give
him $80 million a year and he'd figure
out a way to just give it to everybody
that he ever met you know and be like
I'm broke now uhhuh I'm broke now but
check out this [__] statue didn't
that's he did that was him right yeah he
gave it to I think he gave it a lot a
lot away yeah that's the story goes who
knows if it's true or not but I believe
it dude yeah but when he does that I'm
just like go hammer go hammer go you
know yeah go hammer he's also a pastor I
he didn't he want he kept giving people
money because he's too to quit but I
think that um it's pretty crazy I think
yeah I think someone was like Hey dude
don't give away that money he was like
stop Hammer Time and he started giving
money you know what I mean yeah well at
first he was like you can't touch this
and then he was
like I'm going to soften up a little bit
you I knew it would end up being funny
some I gave that to you I gave that to
you all right let's do the next
one what up boys um I am calling in I
called once before I can tell that's the
worst shirt of all time just from that
area it's a pretty it's a bad shirt I
can tell whatever the rest of that shirt
is it's still no matter what the worst
shirt of all however you cut it that is
a bad shirt that could have my face all
over it on the bottom it's still the
worst show shirt of all time yeah those
shirts everyone see that everyone mhm
don't wear shirts like that yeah hey are
you a diver in 1950 right that's what
you are so that's all good anyway just
[__] a girl God fingerbanged you
know I was paused so anyway go ahead
about the girlfriend
who asks too many questions
and okay thanks what up boys um I am
calling in I called in once before uh
about the girlfriend who asks too many
questions and uh you know at like coffee
shops or whatever and it's just the
worst and takes way too long um there is
no progress on that front um and I've
just learn to place my order and walk
away and she deals with the awkward
social interaction uh I am however
talking about another awkward Ure
interaction but from me okay so I was
just listening to you guys' episode
about uh some chick called in and she
was talking about how everybody in her
family's got the same J sounding name or
whatever and everybody makes the same
jokes and it's the worst and I also hate
the obvious joke um and I like to think
myself relatively witty and clever I
know you guys are going to make fun of
that um but you know it's just the so
social interaction is uh yeah you know I
I pride myself on it I guess you could
say and uh what this guy saying to the
point where I have a couple of those
moments in my life where it's just so
vivid and I think the worst example of
it was I ran into Jay Cutler and um
almost said Heath Ledger but Phil Heath
uh the two bodybuilding dudes like I
don't know if they're still doing that
thing but it was like eight and a half
years ago like that's how how much of an
outlier it is it's Vivid to this day I
was working at a hotel they showed up
waiting for a car and uh you know I was
just kind of chopping it up
professionally and uh you know I was
like well how how's it going to go this
year essentially and uh and Jay C's like
oh well I'm going to win and then he's
going to win the next few years and I uh
I mean I want to say it now but I tried
stopping myself but it just came out and
I was like well you know you're going to
win unless unless I join you know and uh
they both just not even they didn't even
pretend to laugh they literally just
looked at me and they're like yeah we
get that all the time and it was an
absolute gut punch I don't even think I
spoke after that so uh I guess my
question is how do I get that memory out
of my brain first off if that would be
you know possible and secondly I guess
for other people like I said I feel like
I do a pretty good job of avoiding those
moments uh but for your fans and for me
I guess I'll take it is uh how can you
avoid those situations uh going forward
all right guys thanks a lot got it um
you get what he's saying now yeah but
that was the obvious joke he he hates
yeah when he makes it and he hates when
people make it and how do we avoid doing
that uh be
funnier be funnier I mean there's I it's
it's all it takes is before okay it
usually the these jokes happen when you
just met someone and you're either
commenting on their name or what they're
what they do or something like that that
is like a surface level thing that
people know about a person person just
when you meet someone like and the a
joke arises cuz that's how it works we
think of a thing that we think is funny
and then we just blurt it out we don't
usually run it through the the checklist
of like wait is this funny did they get
this a lot but you have to do that for
people you just met do they get this all
the time if the answer is even like
possibly then just don't make that joke
that's it I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't
know that that was a common thing that
bodybuilders got that
joke I don't think I would do that one
but I wouldn't think that they get that
all the time but I guess maybe they do
apparently you're not gonna win if I
join you know I get that makes sense to
me that that it's a thing that people
say really oh wow I guess I'm way off on
that yeah I don't know but I'm not
pissed about it so mad I I uh yeah I
don't know I don't I don't think that
that's I mean you're going to fall into
that trap sometimes dude you know know I
do that I'm a [__] comedian I
probably do it so it's like you you know
I I I I like to pride myself on not
saying the things that are the first
draft jokes you know but but you know
sometimes you do I mean and it's just
going to happen and it's okay and don't
beat yourself up about it you know man
MC Hammer had some hits huh huge hits
like so many yeah well you were the
whole time you were talking you just
could not wait to talk about MC I
couldn't stop thinking about what you
were talking what he was talking I was
like man MC just and we pray every day
or whatever that song is you know he had
a lot of hit and then the do what did
The Adams Family W do what they wanted
to do say what they want to say live how
they want to live you know what I mean
just like a lot of hits at once dude
like in three
years poor guy had no like he's probably
okay now no I'm sure he's okay now but
if he like had any sense of what was
about to happen he could have prepared
for that and made sure that the money
didn't come in and go right like that
sucks dude that song Too Legit to Quit
is a [__] banger do I'm going to
listen to it on the way home not you
can't touch this no you like to Legit to
Quit Better Than You Can't Touch
This Too Legit that [__] that that what
about this
though that part wait which one is the
one that goes hi hi too legit too
hi it's better cuz of the hey hey a g a
gay man that does that even though you
know it's like a fat black lady a gay
man that yeah you know it's a gay man
cuz it's ha a y yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know to legit yeah Too Legit to Quit he
hey
he trying to get someone's attention
sweat sweat dripping all over my chest I
don't remember the [__] John sh I
thought of that when you did that
yeah we used to when we were kids when
we first moved to California we were
friends with this family and and they
had two kids our age a girl Chris's age
a boy my age the boy uh was like just
how would you even describe him he was
such a wild kid wild dude that kid was
Wild free association you like he would
just say [__] that popped into his head
uh and one time Chris started like used
to go to the gym at one point he didn't
see me for a while and I saw him was
like way more muscular he was like oh my
God like I I grew into myself and he was
like oh my God what the heck dude look
at you look at your CH oh my God you
ever just drip water on your chest and
just look at it like that no drift watch
and watch it trickle down between your
pecs like this yeah yeah he said that
and um as if as if they that that was
the thing to ask someone who started
working out like he like no it's even
more like it's like he's been trying to
build his chest so that he can do that
and he's like so needs to know what it's
like for you it was immediate he asked
me that and so funny and the best part
about it is he was younger than me that
was the best part about it because I was
like 17 and he was like 15 yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right um
so anyway he's doing well he is yeah oh
good I I love that family whole yeah the
whole f is amazing yeah um all right
cool well want to do another one yeah do
another so
SC hey Chris and Matt my name is Charlie
Rich I'm phoning you from London England
first of all show I think Matt using
your life experience your general wisdom
you're making a positive impact on
people's lives it's fantastic and Chris
I think you're doing a brilliant job at
finishing math
sentences okay listen my issue is I'm an
actor oh yeah and I have a lot of
financial struggle in a band I'm in the
creative industry so are you to I was
wondering if you can offer any advice or
life experience to help with this I'm at
an age now where people are buying
houses people are settling down they're
having weddings they're having holidays
to nice places and here I am just kind
of surviving month to month um I need
some advice I need I need some help on
how to how to deal with this obviously
just compare myself less that is one
factor if you have something that goes a
bit deeper than that or you could offer
some life experience that's going to
help me thanks
guys yeah I mean everyone's on the own
path though dude you know it's like are
you I don't know are you talented like
he seems like he
probably I mean he probably in a band
right a photographer or something yeah
he could be a photographer yeah he could
totally be yeah I can imagine him be
like let's see look look at this
um um but uh I
just I don't know
man it's just hard well also the truth
is we Mak a joke he looks like he's in a
band we don't know what the thing is
that you do so it's hard to give advice
true about a a a line of work or
whatever you want to call career path
that we're we're guessing about but you
said it's a creative one assuming it's
in the Arts to some degree dude
now probably more than ever it's
almost just in terms of the math yeah
it's almost impossible to make a good
living in the Arts the gig economy has
completely like edged into the artist
life and that those are not really that
compatible gig economy the gig economy
what's that Well everybody's an
independent contractor now no one's an
employee no one's on salary they go from
gig to Gig the gig economy oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh such a [__] idiot dude
everyone at home rewind like 5 10
seconds and watch the way he said oh to
what my explanation about that that's
the dumb and you will see the dumbest
man in the history of the world wow gig
economy is that something it's a term
that people use to describe the present
state of the of the way the workforce
exists in the not know about that and
and that's a real thing well yeah did is
what I said something that lines up with
your
vision of reality I it's true I suppose
so but there's still people that don't
do that well of course but it used to be
almost
everyone who actually made a living made
it through a company they worked for
that they went to that job every day so
yeah I guess I didn't I don't know I
don't know way way way more splintered
and fractured than that I guess I don't
know that and people get by as
independent contractors from job to job
gig to gig I understand that okay I
guess I I guess no I didn't know that
yeah yeah no it's it's definitely like
that M to a much greater degree than it
ever has been before and that makes it
harder because like this guy he's going
from thing to thing to thing and there's
no steady way to accumulate wealth and
to get comfortable put down Roots
whatever the [__] you want to do in life
um but look you know you mentioned
comparing if you're comparing yourself
so much to other people that is starting
to look more attractive what they're
doing than what you're doing not in
result-based way but just in a
day-to-day way then like maybe it's time
to not do what you're doing but you if
you compare yourself to others then you
have to know that your the path you're
on is one very well traveled it's it's
it's littered with people who were were
where you are and are now on the other
end who are much more successful than
you where you are now if you am I am I
saying that right I know what you're
saying yeah I know you're saying you're
just saying it's like you're still on
the path and if you're comparing
yourself you can know that by looking
around at others who've done what you
did and stayed the course and ended up
being successful
yeah I don't know I got so dizzy in the
past two minutes um just completely
dizzy uh that's a shame man you okay
happens to me sometimes I don't know
what's going on yeah I'm probably fine I
hope dearly beloved yeah no that happens
to me all the time really uh yeah yeah
feels like it's like an inner ear nasal
thing or some [__] de beloved and it's
fine but I'm so dizzy and I blame that
guy it's his fault yeah that was talking
about you know what I blame saying gig
economy too
much gigg G gg gg gg baby talk
baby all right you know having a stroke
dude don't do that I want to do it but I
actually don't
I want to do it and I'm going to do it
I've always been that way always
disliked it but I like to do [__] like
this a little brother
dude why do I like it I don't know I
know why I don't only do it to you
though know that so but how is it little
but what does that mean because that's
got to kick your
ass because a little brother would do
some weird [__] like that is that true
because you have a little brother and
that little brother's me and I'm the one
who does does it or do you think that is
very interesting
question I don't care I don't know I
don't care to even get into it I'm real
that's all I know wow and I'm dizzy as
[__] dude I'm so dizzy I don't even
understand what's
happening why did that start happening
God more you need more water you got too
much caffeine did you eat
enough it is that it is that I need I
probably need more water I drank
caffeine uh so much caffeine that's
that's what uh I didn't really drink
that much caffeine jokes on you tricked
you tricked me dude wow [__] got me
dude but um I should drink more water
just as a whole you drink water out of a
bottle like it's it's trying to get out
of your mouth as soon as it went in do
you know
that dude you drink a bottle of water
and you go like this good it's just
running out good what what oh wow good
okay cool you're not going to make me
feel bad about that cool just went to a
Tony Robin
dude just got out of a weekend you do I
want you to drink water and I want you
drink it how you want to do it and then
I want you to be happy about it dude I
love Tony Robbins I'm not going to [__]
around at all dude I love same dude Tony
Robbins he curses at people it's [__]
amazing so how do I get a better job
[__] you [__] basically dude but he's so
nice too say I'm a [__] [__] say it
say it to everyone look in their eyes
say it now what we realize you're [__]
so go out there and get a
job
dude oh [__] and then after the
testimonial with her you know just like
and then the next week I got my dream
job and I just just always works you
know for some reason what was I going to
say I was going to say something oh yeah
I want to know something you you don't
know if I you want to know something or
I scratch that do I want to know
something what are you saying you want
to know something or you were saying I
and then scratch that and you ask me do
I want to know
something but I don't understand the
first one you're
saying well how could do you want to
know something no then that's not the
first one but but how could that have
meant that because you said I want to
know
something I you want to know something
that's what I said okay that's what I
thought you weren't sure if I said that
you or not is really the what comes down
to it okay okay so so now we know that
it wasn't me being dumb it was you kind
of you're being no you were never being
dumb at any point I
agree okay okay what yes I want to know
something yes I don't think you do to be
honest I do but what I'm going to say I
think you don't want to know I'm a
Seeker okay what I'm going to I'm going
to tell you I'm going to tell you
anyway I was
in uh Pittsburgh I did shows one day I
woke up didn't want to work out okay oh
God you feel like you probably don't
want to know what this is I woke up I
was like I got to workout I went down
you didn't want to didn't want to but I
went down I was like let me just be
there at the hotel gym yeah so I was
like you know what I'm going to do I got
there I'm like I'm going to make myself
do 10 uh
pull-ups made myself do 10 pull-ups
that's it no I was done start you mean
yeah just get into it and I was like I'm
still not into it you cuz sometimes you
do some [__] you get into then I was
like I'm going to do
more pull-ups I'm going to do about
eight we were on such a roll you know
and now we're just talking about [__]
pullup then I did six so I was at 16
okay right then I did six so I was at 20
whatever that is wow dude 22 all right
then I did uh six more 128 yeah sorry 28
then I did six more adding 100 to it for
no
reason trying to trick me you know then
I did six more more so I'm up to 228
right
now anyway I kept going dude 6 six six
the devil the devil you knew I was going
to say that dude I going to say
that did you know I knew you going to
say that I knew you knew I that's
awesome I knew you knew I knew you were
going to say that Tony Robins Tony I
knew it gun
dude I knew
it oh God
damn [__]
dude we have to bleep all those out you
know all right dude so I got
to 134 now what Jesus Christ what I'm
realizing now is I don't think that's a
multiple of six no it's not it's
definitely not but
I but but you didn't you started by
doing 10 100 oh right and then you did
six okay so but even still 10 it's still
not the right multi but anyway I 134 oh
okay that might be a multiple of six no
it's not no no hold on is
124 divided
six that's not either no it's not so I
[__] up somewhere along the way yeah
but why did what why what's the
significance of six you didn't need to
do that because that was as many as I
could do each time without the seventh
one was going to be really [__] hard
I don't know if I can do it does
everyone at home realize how quickly I
was able to understand if that was
divisible by six I'm [__] smart I'm
[__] smart rewind watch how fast I
knew those were
not I'm the one that said that but you
asked and I said no because I knew right
talking to a dog that 124 was not
multiple of six hold on so I did did 134
pullup uh pull-ups uh that's so many but
okay and I start I should have started
the story with this I start my workouts
when I do my back I start with 50
pull-ups okay I start with 50 pull-ups
and then I do back okay okay no okay
okay okay that's fine I am it it doesn't
really make me sore to do 50 Pull-Ups so
I was like I'm not going to be sore I
did 134 pull-ups I was so sore the next
day
uh that well there's nothing to discuss
because there's nothing more
understandably [__] obvious than that
I you usually do 50 pull-ups and one day
you did 50 plus 134 and then oh my God
you were sore only 154 34 that's still
[__] almost three times as many but I
don't get why I was so sore when it's
just the same motion over and over again
when I also do other back stuff after
that that is why because it's the same
motion over and over and over and over
and over again to a much greater degree
than what you usually do okay and that's
obvious I just I didn't think I would be
this sore and I am well and I'm going to
do it again today I don't care and I
think I'm going to I'm going to do 135
pull-ups I'm and they don't and they
don't care okay no one in the world
cares my goal is to get to 20 pull-ups
at in a row I I got to 19 in
2021 you couldn't just do one more you
[__] couldn't I couldn't I I can't
yeah well you're going to be able to
soon if you keep doing 134 now I can do
14 or 15 in a row okay okay okay I'm
just saying dude I know okay I yeah it's
pretty good it's good especially cuz I'm
I'm sit at 205 I I walk like a ball
player but I want you know I I I I want
I want to be you know done you want to
be done talking about this that's what I
want cuz I was say we have the same
desire if that's what want all right
whatever man we got silly this episode
anyway all right look I'm going to be in
Phoenix I'm going be in Sacramento I'm
going to be in uh
Brea uh El Paso what the [__] dude grow
or die my special is available at Chris
lea.com also go on over to uh
patreon.com Lifeline lxury where Matt
and I [__] we got another show
Lifeline luxury it's the same as this
only no
submissions uh and private record Matt's
uh new uh podcast yeah go to private
record.com follow us on Instagram Tik
Tok And subscribe on
YouTube all right I'm not dizzy
[Music]
nice you got a question you want to be
on this show click the link in the
description below or go to watch
life.com you want to oneone with me you
want to one one11 with me go to mag.com
and book it give you the best advice you
ever had and if you want the merch last
minute holiday shopping Lifeline
merch.com Booyah booya and booah all
right
hello
hello hello please
hello hello